welcome to this video playing Westphalia
from Germany serially from Westphalia
there's no text and there the face is
probably not living too far away from me
okay so we got an open soohyun that's
the town variation okay I'll stay within
typical Sicilian territory not playing
c4 which of course was possible that the
maracas see bind could have been set up
but I have played the malach see bind
them set up so often as white and just
from the English opening and this kind
of night Knight f3 and type of positions
so that when I play you fall for a
change in like to have a typical evil
position just to get a different
different flavor in a way okay maybe I
can do something on the queenside here
he lost some time I can play defy here
maybe my idea was that well a5 is not
really great because of c3 and the
position opens up to my advantage I
think but this is in fact a good move if
I go de 5 he will play 94 probably and
jabbered not much choice okay I need to
I need to do it probably takes away
maybe have could have taken and played a
five that's that really I could have
done what I was my idea was to try to
use the the better development that I
have with with c3 okay I'm trying that
this was the idea connected with e5 but
I should have thought a bit longer
because he takes d5 and probably f5
happy next move from it was very likely
strong
sorry for the sounds now that wasn't so
loud able to open a bottle okay took on
c3 and so this was my idea and now
taking with the night so that afore
hangs now he can take on me too but this
further speeds up my development maybe
it is not okay didn't now now he for
Hanks and the idea is to continue
quickly with Bishop e3 and xe1 trying to
play against the Queen on c7 here still
two moves away from castling and it's a
question if you really should cover your
form yeah takes quite quite some time
maybe maybe a move like queen bee 60 k
interesting key interesting way to cover
yeah but I don't I don't really want to
take a look at the moment I want to play
Roxy one and use the engine development
look a to see one probably and yeah I
guess so I don't think that far will be
of any importance anytime soon well the
rook on a one might be useful on a one
especially if I can somehow wind a six
born that can easily happen then the
rook is just ready on the afar to
support the f up on what the f one look
is never doing anything only idea could
have been to play rook ac-12 have hook
ft one that could have been interesting
but to be honest i'm not quite sure what
his next move is I really only see
quindi eight and this is not like the
move you dream about I'm threatening
night b5 and 95 m
that's not exactly great that you need
to do that I think you needed to do that
but um still it's not clear how I am how
a benefit from that and I could play
Knight d2 just try to win you for a five
not sure not quite sure how to how to
play this would have been very nice
forget in before but ok I need to need
to play 92 and I try that 92 taking on
your form but yeah the night on be three
years it wasn't doing so much I think
black is probably all right iam ok f5
for the for the block here right c4
yeah I wonder if the night is doing
something great on c4 or I take it I
can't take it actually night takes yeah
why not actually I can I can do that I
don't see a big disadvantage and taking
and now maybe night c4 I can also go to
e5 and I have bishops e6 and Knight b6
official b6 and 96 possibly to arrest
the Queen yeah not sure about the
position at all well this I didn't see
you did sir completely completely
ignored interesting rules now I cannot
really move the Queen away it's not too
great as c4 is hanging and if I take it
he's got a strong part III I guess ya
know not to move not to grade really
maybe I get the d3 porn but still he's
got two bishops on an open board there
so this is always to be respected 95 is
what I would reckon with now maybe just
play that I can take on d5 take d3 but
he will have firm definite compensation
I taken now there's also Knight g4 I am
yeah but still I need to take the pawn
okay and maybe here trying to get rid of
at least one of the bishops it returns
fo I'll i know but not cannot so sure
how bad that is maybe it is bad
yeah let's look F 2 we are possibly okay
maybe 93 well okay I need to I need to
play no use in spending any more time
Jack can go to e3 maybe but that's I
don't think so so big a deal probably
where am i going to see one I probably
hear my morning probably here no it
takes this night be 78 Bishop takes rook
g1 it looks a bit it looks a bit strange
for black being somehow tied up with the
pieces can do I want to take them or
maybe maybe this the night on c5 is very
very annoying for black maybe 96 even
yeah no I can take a six but I'd like to
go here also controlling the f7 for
possible made ideas route da that's 96
okay let's make them look for the king
now just take here okay well this side
these are nice nice Knights okay maybe I
can even grab f sub north I g7 don't
threaten made in two books g7 night f7
mate I didn't even see that beforehand
but that's very strong i think i dont
even adult see a defense at the moment I
don't
yeah I can't can still take it of course
and now maybe just move the rock away
okay well he somehow the time lost is
not register now that's weird black for
Fitz and ya know yet he does not have
any move I think I mean can take a 411 I
mean why does what is just much better
than these nights are just are just
amazingly strong controlling all the key
squares of the king and he cannot attack
them even so I will just get this pawn
yeah that was tricky probably black was
fine i mean i don't i don't think i
should be any better here the 11 point
was that here I really should have maybe
thought a moment longer and considered
to take I computers actually quick to
point out that Bishop g5 is the better
move this is this is some also possible
I didn't really thought if I for so good
but it seems to be okay it looks a bit
tricky and this opposition but not it's
not so dramatic okay so the computer
actually likes this but not c3m once to
play Bishop e3 yeah okay well it's
playable for white anyway but this this
shouldn't be shouldn't be fantastic on
computer i think that white is much
better here but i don't really see how I
look T one night be three back and then
roop t1 yeah that's strange I'd wants to
get the night to d4 because now he six
this week are that's a good idea and an
idea that I didn't consider yam that
strong that's just strong play
you're intending 94 to put pressure only
six and after castles the result some
like Quincy for just directly attacking
this and what exactly i doing now white
is just better okay this is what I
should have done and well here there's
probably many ways for black to get ya
the computer actually wants to play the
95 move that I had suggested during the
game and says equal just that equal yeah
black black always has enough play here
he's got this big porn on on be to a4 is
slightly bigger for slightly weakened
there at the two bishops oh it's it
should be okay at least but this was
certainly not not terrible i Luke t8 is
a good move here for black yeah okay we
both had about a minute so cannot expect
perfect chest ok and here the computer
also points out I didn't see that now I
saw that of course but what I didn't see
is that in this check sequence that be
to at the entrance and this means that
black is winning here okay the sea could
have done so it was a really lucky win
yeah no I know it gets it gets tricky
you at the night coming to e6 and he
couldn't really manage that in this time
travel okay thanks for watching